what did the making of this American
Journey teach you about people you know
you're dealing with the heartland yeah
vs new york and LA which are so used to
well what the film taught us I told us
things on many things on many levels but
I think one of the main things that you
know it's borne out watching the film is
you know how quickly we are to judge
people based on their appearance and
their location well I'm here and here
they're talking like that and they dress
like that so a lot of it we're going to
get a bit of this you know but if you
had to sit down you you know spend a
little moment talking listening to
people it's amazing what you're actually
find and it's not that far you know
beneath the surface and yet obviously
for the sake of a lot of people who like
to divide label and divide people so
that people can actually be controlled a
bit more easily manipulated more easily
you know a lot of this sort of divisive
pneus labeling is encouraged and what we
discovered you know getting out there is
that we got more in common than we have
different I mean how we talk what we
dress like or what you know union or
association we belong to or whatever
people have got more in common than they
have different you know when times are
tough like they have been in this
country to me it makes more sense to
dwell on what on the good things that we
have in our lives in order to get out of
the the Maya you know so well it's to
unlearn the good things that we've got
what we might have in common in order to
sort of get out of these difficult times
as opposed it was your fault you did
this you did that more you're just those
kind of people so what are you going to
do you know the finger-pointing and
nonsense and he just stuck in the same
place so to me it's like you know what
we've got a lot more in common than me
after different we're all in this
together so let's try and get out of it
together by dwelling on the positive and
that's what I think you know we learn
ourselves in this film is that you see
examples of that in the film and it also
really illuminates yourself because it
could see like you know it shows you it
showed me anyway how much I judge people
and presume them to be a certain type of
person and then you sit there go or if
I'm
nothing in honor because there just
wasn't the case and there's something
that people say a lot about when they
watch the film and it's you know it's
really uplifting and inspiring because
you got people in very unexpected places
unexpected time saying these really sort
of like heartening things you look at it
you like you know what this thing is all
right this country's all right it's did
with these people with this American
spirit intact like it is people will
learn it's a young country and people
will learn from these experiences we all
learn from experience it's good or bad
and that's what the country is doing now
and that's what the people of this in
the film show us you know you walk away
going like I think it's going to be all
right you know he like how great you
know and it's the people of the film
that that our interviewees it show us
that
you